Who's, who's funding, uh,
President Julius Malema
then who does he's,
who's the people we are funding?
Ah, but, but, but,
but there's a very close relationship with uh,
the mazotis
there's no free lunch at first,
I mean they never refused or they never said we are not,
they funded them when they established the,
the party but now remember there's this law
you declare whoever is funding.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, funding
so they are no longer being funded by people
but if they are funded,
they will declare that
I mean, look,
abo NC nabo d a
they are funded by the Oppenheimers
Abo action s a d a light
Abo Mzansi whatever
so yeah, yeah,
they are funded by them
exactly. And I mean remember,
and that's what also pays for that money
because I'm a poster,
expensive printing,
it's cost, it's a lot.
It's million.
How many do you think you need?
Like good amount. Ah,
well, with the C R17
when we were estimation was almost around um,
billion yoh,
billion when you calculate the money in South 1 million
a million but
now they have, yeah,
they only have because of the para
para dollars because we don't know where,
where are they?
Before we get to para Para,
why don't you disclose the findings of Cosasana Dlamini
Zuma's uh, campaign in 2017?
Uh, that campaign there was,
there was no complaint which,
which was lodged, okay,
um, against her
remember? Oh,
president who Deputy President
investigating him was the complaint lodged by my money
in terms of the law.
And in terms of that law,
only members of Parliament can lodge a complaint.
So who? President,
deputy president
then SIM investigated because it was a complaint.
A complaint.
But as well
he was the deputy president.
I didn't have jurisdiction over her
because she was from the a U. Remember?
She was still just an ordinary person then that
they should have opened a criminal case against her.
Whoever is complaining about AMA campaign fund.